well this movie opens up a lot of
possibilities for Sony and spider-man
[Music]
spider-man into the spider-verse
so into the spider verse is a spider-man
animated adventure with Miles Morales
spider-man it's actually an origin story
of Miles Morales spider-man always he's
been doing this for years Peter Parker
spider-man's in this movie he has been
doing this for years but they come
together and something happens and the
spider verse gets fractured and other
spider-man's get brought into the
adventure and spider people spider-gwen
and a spider cartoon pigs and I'll bring
on the adventure it's a really fun
adventure too it's not just fun I mean
fun is in here but it has heart you get
invested you're really gonna attach to
Miles Morales you see that he's at this
yuppie school it's just kind of a fish
out of water he's really feel for the
dude so I feel like if you're a Miles
Morales fan going into this movie you're
really gonna feel like the movie did him
justice if you're not a Miles Morales
fan this will bring you over to the
Miles Morales side of things he's a
legit spider-man really likable dude but
the movie was hilarious it was funny as
hell to the war spider-man was
hysterical having on the floor funny
when I was driving home I was comparing
this to the Raimi spider-man movie and
the Raimi spider-man even the amazing
spider-man he doesn't actually get the
spider-man suit he doesn't become
spider-man till about an hour into the
movie this movie is longer he doesn't
actually get his stride until the end
most of the movie is him learning about
it getting a handle on it like the Raimi
spider-man skipped over that part he's
like I have these powers Uncle Ben died
then it zooms into the artwork and then
now he's been spider-man for a while
this with Miles Morales not Peter Parker
is that in between
it's the growing pains it's him learning
it's him trying to figure it out and
being mentored by Peter Parker when I
saw the trailer I was like Peter Parker
kind of looks like a slob who doesn't
care I don't know if I like that there
is a story-based reason for it it
actually works really well for those
movies the animation stylin here's a
funny thing because it is stylistic it's
pretty slick for the most part it
absolutely does work for the type of
action based animation they want to show
here on the other hand though the
animation smooth is but or sometimes
some other times it looks like the
animation drops frame rate I imagine
it's purposely done not accidental like
when you're streaming something and it
drops frame right it goes from smooth
and when people are interacting it looks
like they're almost in the stop-motion
animation type of frame rate you get
used to it the animation does work for
the story but they're trying to do is it
make a comic book come to life
essentially this animation style does
work for that and after that you slip
into it you really appreciate what the
animation does for the action sequences
that click frame animation
lend itself to action being very fast so
it makes for very exciting spider-man
action when it's going down so in the
end it really does work any negatives I
have is like they're just gripes really
their nitpick it runs into essentially
what the Raimi spider-man movies run
into her at least spider-man 2 because
that was the one with the villain who
was essentially a normal dude like Doc
Ock has tentacles but he's a normal guy
he's not super power so when Spiderman
punches him in the face I feel like you
should be out there was actually one
joke again I'm gonna say nitpicks there
was one joke in here that had to do with
the pig that kind of I feel like it
broke the fourth wall like - a Deadpool
degree and I don't know if the pig is
supposed to be like that but it was said
by someone else not the pig but I did
feel like leave them out of humor -
Deadpool and let's do spider-man stuff
here again I said nitpicks but something
just stood out to me because in the end
spider-man into the spider verse was a
very fulfilling spider-man origin story
it's a word I had when I walked out of
it I was like it was very fulfilling
it's a great coming-of-age story it's a
great superhero origin story it's a
Spider Man origin story you haven't seen
on the big screen a hundred times or at
least twice it has heart it's exciting I
like Miles Morales I like the supporting
cast all the voice acting was great
which is plenty more Hershel alley plays
Miles Morales is uncle in this movie
which is the same character Donald
Glover played in spider-man homecoming
very irrelevant for this review but I
think it's cool Miles Morales you are
cool you have solidified yourself as a
legit spider-man in my eyes sorry I'm a
little late to that party not only did I
like Miles Morales but I liked his
relationship with Peter Parker or at
least this universe is Peter Parker it
was it was a really good story but I
will say spider-man into the spider
verse is definitely worth watching
definitely worth buying on blu-ray I am
curious as to the possibilities this
opens up for Sonia really am there are
some spider-man's stories I would
totally love to see on screen in the
vein of this animation like right now
I'm currently reading superior
spider-man I'm in the second trade I'm
not too far but I'm really digging it
superior spider-man's when doctor
octopus's consciousness has swapped with
Peter Parker so it's doc Ock's mind in
Peter Parker's body and he's like I can
be a way more efficient spider-man than
he was I'm not gonna waste it like him
I'm gonna be a superior spider-man that
was reading it just last week I was
thinking I was like we will never see
this story on the big screen but after
this I maybe that'd be really cool see a
superior spider-man story in the vein of
this animation or an original spider my
story I'm just saying this is the
Goldilocks zone for Sony you don't have
to compete with the MCU do your own
thing this is totally their own
you knocked it out of the park all right
so spider-man into the spider-verse have
you seen it what did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]